what's up guys we're from fancy today
we're back with another episode of
challenge confidency if you're wondering
what happened to make us here go check
out the 500k special video but now to
the challenges
[Music]
okay so I've shaved my hair off
specifically to find out if I can play
with it
[Music]
pretty good head drop good neck exercise
here
[Music]
my eye
[Music]
nice my headset Oh
[Music]
I haven't received a neo but maybe I'll
start using this stuff yeah you actually
wonder fine yeah
all right now let's try playing off the
wall
[Music]
Oh feel like we're playing squash or
something
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh all right so this is an interesting
idea let's fill the cups and why are we
even filling the cups
I don't know idea you're mine okay
I'll I should put some more no no no
this is turd boy okay let's leave the
water out no more water looks like we're
going to a very strange birthday party
oh so cool your ball was in the way
[Music]
all right so I think we had some pretty
good challenges today yeah I make sure
you keep leaving those comments and
ideas in the comment section below
I remember to subscribe here and watch
your previous episodes
there until next time